[Music]
Chuck I got another explainer for you
awesome this one is things you can do
with chemical energy
interesting yeah yeah there are other
kinds of energies that we know about
there's like crystal crystal
energy crystal energy yes not the not
the type of energy that you know brings
about wellness and and healing and yeah
crystals are the lowest energy state of
their
configuration so they contain no energy
to give no no nothing they got nothing
for they got nothing to give and they
have such low energy they're they're
they're very permanent right um things
that can drop to another energy state
they're not so permanent in in the
environment but crystals are that's why
there's like
salt forever
everywhere just it went from the most
valuable substance on Earth the most to
the point where we have saying like is
worth his weight and salt to zero
value because salt just diging up from
two million year old dried L bit is
still there all
right energy yeah chemical energy so
this is energy stored inside the
atom inside the and among the
electrons of the atom okay to be
distinguished from nuclear energy right
so the the nucleus of an atom is nuclear
energy so energy can take many different
forms it's kinetic energy energy of
motion okay okay so chemical energy is
what's the energy source of traditional
bombs okay makes sense that's what
that's that's chemical energy chemical
energy is in all of our Rockets right
okay you ignite it the rocket takes off
it's converting one set of chemicals
into another set of chemicals and it's
releasing energy okay okay and we call
that exothermic exothermic you can also
have a set of chemicals that turn into
other chemicals and they absorb energy
we would call those what endothermic
endothermic and we might have seen those
if you play weekend softball because the
first St kit has a little packet you
shake it you slap it and then it turns
cold cold right cold pack cold pack it's
cold pack cold packs cold packs and you
have hot packs which is exothermic all
right that's all chemical energy now
suppose I want to store the chemical
energy and use just as much as I need at
any given moment well that wouldn't be a
bomb because that releases it all at
once right okay okay you you ignite TNT
it's done but suppose I want to sort of
leak it out when I need it just as much
as I need for that
moment when you set up a device that has
chemical energy work that way for you we
call that a
battery
sweet gotcha as opposed to now let me
think let's extend this out as opposed
to like a gas tank because that's just
holding the gas okay that's true that's
true so the gas gas the actual the
actual uh uh uh um uh interaction
happens in the engine the gas is only
pushing it through a line so it can
explode inside that chemical reaction in
the gas in the engine what kind of car
are you talking
about com
fashion yeah yeah you know remember
I I know I know what you drive so
remember those remember those things you
know right after the horse we got
that it's exactly
right way back somebody just said all
right I'm done with horses let's let's
figure out another way to do that so so
the difference there of course gasoline
is also chemical energy High very high
dense chemical energy but you're only
using like little bits of it at a yes
and you draw it as you need it that's
true but we wouldn't call that a battery
right exactly okay now I the question is
could you make a battery out of gasoline
I
maybe it that's a dangerous battery
man that's a very d i maybe I hadn't
thought about that okay let me tell you
how batteries work so when you have a
neutral atom it has exactly as many
electrons as protons cancelling the
electric field so that it is net neutral
in charge okay okay suppose I take away
an
electron uh
oh now I have a negative charge where I
have the electron because all electrons
are negatively charged and then left
over the atom now has a positive charge
positive charges it's got one more
proton than electrons in orbit around it
right and as you know opposite charges
attract attract so they want to come
back together right right they want to
come back together damn baby is that why
you Le me like
that personifying oh my I'm talking good
physics here and you got to make it
a just trying to get back with you girl
that's all I'm trying to do I feel out
of balance I feel
negative my life has been a negative
Journey oh baby you're the only positive
thing in my life girl I need you back
come on
now all right so uh if you separate
those charges they want to come back
together okay all right you have to ask
how badly do they want to do this you're
talking about electromagnetic forces
which are
huge okay huge I'll give an example
example if you took away all the
electrons from like the top
cubic ctim in the tip of the Space
Shuttle take all those electrons out and
stick it at the base of the
Launchpad okay the space shle would not
be able to take
off what kind
of what the hell is that these are some
powerful forces operating wow the the
the electrons you pulled away will be
attracting the positive chart well what
would happen is it take off and blast
hole through the thing okay I mean they
would come back together and the engines
would still go up but if it was all
rigidly attached it would not be able to
take off against the thrust of the Eng
that's how powerful that's how powerful
electromagnetic forces are way stronger
than gravity like by by by 40 orders of
magnitude stronger than gravity okay
gravity gravity you could just bend down
and pick up a rock
right against the wishes of the entire
mass of the Earth yes okay
electromagnetic forces actually kick
sand in the face of gravity as a force
[Music]
yes introducing the all electric Ford
Mustang mock SUV Ford is electrifying
its icons to keep the so of driving
alive while shifting towards an electric
vehicle future the Mustang Mach e is an
SUV with the Bold style of a Mustang
which means you can make a bold
statement and still be practical the
2023 Mustang Mach e GT performance
Edition SUV achieves 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds it's an EV with exhilerating
torque and available features like
electric all-wheel drive and a drive
mode called unbridled it has room for
you your people and your things with
five seats and a frunk other wise known
as a front trunk experience the freedom
and Thrill of the drive while knowing
your needs can still be met learn more
about the all electric Ford Mustang Mach
SUV at
ford.com SUVs
slachy e due to high demand and Global
Supply Chain constraints some models
trims and features may not be available
or may be subject to change check with
your local dealer for current
information for the 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds for test data is based on a
typical industry methodology using one
foot rollout your results May Vary back
to the battery so I have this this atom
here atom of my choice different atoms
will behave differently but that's fine
and I want to separate the electron that
takes energy right obviously you have to
pull it away so you pump energy into the
system drag all the electrons away from
all the atoms and store them over in
this other side right okay all right and
you gotta you gotta pre prevent them
from spontaneously coming back so you
got to put barriers in there and stuff
okay now if you want the electrons to
come back you set up a wire connecting
one end to the other and the electrons
can flow get to the other side right
throw flow freely or but generally
you'll put some load in there a light
bulb a computer right a car some you're
gonna put something in there to convert
the chemical energy to electrical energy
right because it's a flow of electrons
and that electrical energy is at your
disposal to turn into kinetic energy to
move a car to um to
what the needs of your computer to run
circuits for for the for the rabbits
playing drums across your carpet um
batteries can then do anything you need
for doing so but eventually what happens
well they run out yeah all all the
electr run out of electrons they're
reattached and we used to just throw
away those batteries right okay right oh
so now you need elect electrical you
need the electrical to go back into the
battery to store again the electrons so
that you can start to process all over
again exactly exactly so that's why
rechargeable batteries have to be
differently um conceived inside compared
to regular batteries okay of course if
you stick a rechargable battery into a
car MH then the car uses the full charge
and then you recharge it well I was
thinking one giant D
battery there's a big giant D battery
just shove it in the back of the
car it's got to take two batteries it
always takes two put in there yeah one
going the opposite I don't know anything
that you ever use one D battery that's
true you're absolutely right I can't
think of one thing that ever Ed One D
battery yeah think about that right and
don't ask me because I don't have the
answer why is it there's double A and
AAA batteries but no single a and why is
it there why are there C batteries and D
batteries but there's no B batteries
don't ask me cuz I don't
know
so rechargeables they need a way for
things to go back both directions right
okay they
clever designs within and depending on
what chemicals are used in the old days
they had lead acid batteries right lead
batter you heard lead batteries right
they're good for cars because they have
very um you can draw from them a very
big impulse of current which was good
for starting the engine back in the old
days just after horses they would crank
you know remember the crank the crank
yeah okay the crank was okay then they
became an electric starter all right
that was a big advance so you didn't
have to get all dirtied with your top
hat okay by cranking the engine on your
way to the Monopoly
board
your top monoc let me crank my car I
must go by Baltic
Avenue now by the way depending on what
the chemical remember there was nickel
cadmium batteries right there was
lithium batteries lithium ion batteries
okay so what what is an ion an ion is
that thing that does not it's the atom
that doesn't have a balanced charge
right okay so you pull away the electron
you've left a positive ion you could
also force feed an electron onto an atom
so it has an extra electron then it's
have a negative ion right so you can
have negative or so that's what an ion
is so this is the fundamentals of a
battery and some batteries will move the
electrons some will move the ions and
some will move both in some in some uh
in some choreography that enables you to
separate the charges the charges come
back and separate them again every time
you recharge so that's the fundamentals
of a battery battery brilant I will say
it is brilliant but right now what comes
to mind is something that I found out
from you by mistake which is when we
send anything into outer space what we
are really doing is taking a tank of
hydrogen and a tank of oxygen and
combining them to make an exothermic
reaction which then leaves you with
water and I do not understand why we are
trying to make cars with batteries when
we could just use that oh oh okay good
question are you ready go ahead uh
because hydrogen is
explosive go go go have that
conversation with the Hindenburg okay
and come back talk to me after oh I got
you that makes sense maybe you could
make a vessel that contains the the
hydrogen because you have to separate
the hydrogen and oxygen to begin with
from your water all right that takes
energy you know how much energy that
takes the same energy you get out when
they come back together oh okay there's
no such thing as a free lunch year in
fact it cost you a little more energy
from the laws of thermodynamics so your
car and there's some cars that are
trying to do this it's called a hydrogen
fuel cell where you have hydrogen over
here and oxygen over there it comes
together it makes energy and it drives
your car okay then you got to drop off
somewhere and and and and fill up your
hydrogen okay or find some way to to
break apart the hydrogen and oxygen in
your moving vehicle as it is you'd stop
by the water Filling Station like the
railroads used to do and that would be
your and but you still need a thing to
make that happen or you might have solar
driven cars okay where where the skin of
the car is is solar panels right okay
but then you can only drive in the
daytime oh yeah I forgot about that Yeah
well yeah well you got to store the
energy guess what you're going to store
the energy in a battery thank you thank
you so there you have it Chuck I you
know and all these different the chemist
battery chemistries all have different
um uh uh features pluses and minuses
among them and the latest sort of best
battery for so many of our needs is a
lithium ion battery right and it's
usually the El lithium the third element
created in the beginning of the universe
the hydrogen then helium then lithium so
it's Cosmic actually okay we can't beat
that tell you well that's that's full
circle for everything we
do all right so Chuck thanks for being
there for this always a pleasure yet
another explainer for our Star Talk
audience uh Neil degrass Tyson as always
bidding you to keep looking
up
[Music]